all right hey we are laugh the last word
with nor convey no any boxes but we got
some special guests by the campfire
today man what's going on well there has
been a crazy crazy community effort and
we were lucky enough to get a couple
people who were involved in the art team
for the big puzzle there's I mean the
whole community helped with everything
but we got a couple people who were
definitely had their nose to the
grindstone for a little while may have
lost some sleep so we want to get them
into the last word in proper fashion so
I'm sending it right back to you give
them given that proper introduction see
if we can make a blog here we go they
gotta get I gotta get the Royal
Treatment let's see welcome to the last
word episode number 88 and it's another
glorious Friday and we're back in from
the campfire for some more Luda shooter
discussion I'm extremely excited about
our special guests so we're gonna get
right into this I want to introduce two
lords could I only play an integral part
in galvanizing our brilliant minds
within the Destiny community but
ultimately help produce the final map
that resolved the true path for one of
desti tools most complex puzzles ever
the corridors of time introducing first
the Lord of IT security and spreadsheet
algorithm creation who just happens to
be a passionate gamer and introducing
second the Lord of the corridors egg dev
team twitch affiliate and the grim
Finity of hexagon affinity laughable
amazing destiny community teams and both
kind enough to make their debut within
the realm of the last word Lords I Corps
and eat the law how you Lords doing baby
no not to break up a fight yeah we're
gonna bring you in in proper fashion
read intro yeah well you better thank
you good to have you guys in a man just
I love to see the community come
together with an event like this and to
see your guys involvement was truly
tremendous I know we gonna get in - he
got allowed to talk about allowed to
discuss but I
is only right gotta show you guys the
proper respect been here at the last
words come come closer to the campfire
gather round it's story time
let's fit you amongst family you're my
family it's really it's really warm
actually I'd say I'm slightly shocked I
mean you're sitting on a campfire
burning myself so you gotta use those
sticks if you're getting those s'mores
going so get a little distance from that
fire we're gonna start and go through
and get a little bit from each you guys
just like where you're at the community
how you guys were involved in this one
and honestly just a little bit about so
we're gonna start with aether so man how
did you get into this puzzle like kind
of give us a little background on your
destiny history and just kind of how you
how you managed to get yourself in and
kind of what's your art a piece of the
big giant puzzle no pun intended but pun
intended was absolutely
well I'm playing destiny sense since d1
days it was a way for me to basically
make friends because I wasn't I wasn't
super popular in high school so I got to
play come home and play destiny with my
best friend Chris and because all he did
was video games and so that was the way
that we communicated and then our
friendship grew and grew and grew and
then we graduated high school and we
were still were super super close he's
my best friend and her nesting 2 came
out I was like all right like let's keep
going with this thing I enjoy doing this
so so let's keep going and it's so funny
because eventually he's a super huge
nerd and eventually I surpassed his
knowledge of destiny and it blew his
mind but destiny for me has always been
about making friends about making
connections with other people so the
next natural way to do that of course is
to get involved with the community I've
been super involved with the community
now since season of The Drifter
was when I started getting more involved
and it's been the coolest experience
ever um as far as how I got involved
with this puzzle this is actually a
super funny story
so I wasn't sleeping no I'm just kidding
I didn't feel like sleeping for a week
so okay the I was when the puzzle came
out I was actually at work working on a
project and I was really upset with
myself because I couldn't be there to
actually check the obelisk sand cuz I
love puzzles you know and I love
challenges and so when I got home I'm
like I want to get involved with this as
quick as I can and it had been about
four or five hours in and so I basically
I'm like where's the community at let me
be wherever the community is at solving
this thing so I got into the
nitty-gritty with a group from raid
secrets
nice nice nice yeah and and then it just
started becoming entirely memes and chat
no one was focusing on the puzzle and I
got ya and I'm like no no we need to
focus down on this and so hotplate um
who's a mod on raid secret was like okay
here I'm moving you guys to like my
private raid secrets discs or giving you
guys a channel you guys just work in
there and and so we did and eventually
once the puzzles brute forced and and so
on and so forth we get to that final
room and get that image and we're like
oh this means something so we started
taking screenshots it's naturally the
majority of the community did and
posting them in this little discord
group right so I said okay well this
isn't going to work because we don't
know whose is whose and if it changes on
the hour how do we know which hour
you're taking it I'm like so this is
what we're gonna do we're gonna take our
images and put one on top one on bottom
and you're gonna put your name at the
bottom so I know who you are
around that time the streamers needed
more photos so hop is like oh well I've
got a team taking photos right now pulls
all the photos and gives them to the
streamers and of course the first one
she gives the streamers is mine with my
watermark logo on this plug shameless
plug we're like why the heck did this
guy water Marcus butter they're like
don't be this guy like please don't be
this guy because hop didn't say like
behind why it was like that and so I'm
like oh no I don't want to be known as
that guy because a lot of these
streamers I know some of them and and
then the others that I don't know I look
up - mm-hmm
like I don't want to I don't want to be
known for this right oh yeah I had
watermarks image mm-hmm so I started
going through every single picture I
went through 250 Wow um screenshots and
found zero matches damn Wow
dado and his community I think found the
first match for the puzzle and I was
like
well I want to do something and start
putting these images together if we're
finding matches and so hop tells
everyone hey we've got I've got a guy
who's DMing me right now going through
all these messages let's just get him in
here mm-hmm and so that was the story of
how I got involved with it as far as
everything else
I started hand matching these different
puzzle pieces and eventually luckily TJ
came in and had his glorious website
that just completely imagine if I was
still doing that by hand I mean we'd
still be here yeah and so my role kind
of shifted to art dev-team kind of
organizing everything I guess because
none of us were full-on managers because
we didn't want anyone we want everyone
on an equal level basically throughout
this whole project and it was is my way
of gain involved with community and
giving back to the community that gave
to me and probably one of the most
exciting weeks of my life I didn't want
to sleep that's all so it was it was
crazy by the way everybody came together
I mean the nights everybody's up you
know just put pooling resources and
doing that thing there's a huge
responsibility we got a yeah we got Zico
a little role in this too right yeah
story gets a little background and
destiny and then how you stumbled into
this chaos
and so
I've always been a gamer and I'm a
everyone that's me eivol a fire playing
my games my xbox I'm a bee sting and you
gotta fail you got a fan you're good
you're right in here with with with
louder but I was told that two in a row
I started up on xbox destiny too and
just stayed there and it wasn't until
and you crossed compatibility or save a
mean I believe to cook with my PC and
and started paying more I'm a PC I don't
really get involved with clams that much
I don't really gain that much with other
people I like to chug along and do my
own thing and find my own path and I've
made some brilliant people playing
destiny and people oh go back do raise
with every now and then but it's I've
always kind of been a
the longer when it comes to that I in
destiny I like to do everything that my
own and and in this puzzle I didn't
actually know about the puzzle until the
day so I missed that about two days
didn't know anything about it was at
work was not aware of it got home
started playing destiny
went EDC obelus to try and
some fat saline and as usual couldn't
actually do anything with it so I just
was staring at these images and I didn't
what they were so I looked at but from
the Internet the raid secrets and that's
when I found it and so I started taking
more obviously puzzled wanted would have
been souls by that point and digging
started investigating more and got
mm-hmm looked all the streamers and what
they were doing in this this other
puzzle this larger puzzle is quite quite
a bit done by that point there was what
like 600 500 600 pieces found but open
on language it and and I just started
going through the reddit post finding
the different data sources from people
finding all the different spreadsheets
that people had shared doing on streams
getting their data sources and then I
pulled them all together and I had about
7,000 point for that point individuate
line Wow and then started working on
different algorithms and AI learning
assault and transcribed them back don't
find the errors mm-hm
and I found a triple the first triple
that was found the same and appeared in
three times you only thought it could
happen twice and I was trying to get
hold of some of the string misters they
look this is a mistake is if you found
this that can you ask the users is there
any more and shall be responded to me
and got me in touch with someone the
glad during bradster okay and then I was
still [ __ ] through doing my own thing
and I think I produced one of the
executive had maps and so that the
largest states at that point was like a
thousand and 23 yeah right and then I
just got dragged into a chat with hop
and AJ and I'm sure it was you
they were law yep and was like where did
you get this data from where where did
you build the map from and I was like no
I just got the data from all over the
place and then I got from this link
which hadn't been leaked at that point
and it just went from there how kind of
our team then there was seven other and
it took over the master master she that
everything was being fed into from six
or seven different streamers from
different communities from portal
cruncher ready from boat explorers all
that date was being fed into us and it
was our the algorithms that I had made
and things like that that were speeding
up the process and that's kind of why we
got it done in five days I think if we
were still using the old spreadsheet and
we would have got it done in six will be
there to the 28 first anyway I got back
in depth team Oh
after the first day I didn't really do
much transcribing I was bored improving
the algorithms we used in the a I wrote
and to speed up the efficiency make it
more accurate you're doing right you
Anna you had a role as far as the are
not having bings match right so like
people would put incorrect entries and
things of that nature I see you respond
for that you know as far as the artwork
and stuff like that I've seen you know
what you were doing either I guess my
question to both of you
is like when did you guys realize like
this thing is taking on a grand like a
bigger scope then you could even imagine
like when did it hit like okay we not
gonna be done in a day so the first
image that circulated of matches to all
the streamers was an image that I
created with it literally had like five
or ten matches on it like it wasn't this
this big thing and I was like oh this is
probably because because they pulled me
in to Tran they're like how big do you
think this is I'm like what we haven't
had any matches so that definitely means
this thing's bigger than 50 mm and I'm
like this is probably probably about a
hundred
150 I'm like there's no way to tell at
this point right and here in my feeble
little mind I'm like oh this probably
only has like 100 200 pieces I can't see
Bungie going crazier than that and it
was it was about when we hit a thousand
pieces right right before we brought in
Zico and wells I Corps brought in nice
really guys I'm doing this yet on my
trade it was this moment where I pull
hop into a private chat and I said you
don't understand and she's like oh yeah
they'll be done by like tonight I'm like
happy to understand I'm like this
thing's big big dawned on us that oh god
we might be here for days and then that
was when Dylan TMG tweeted out that it
would be that it's American maritime
yeah so I wrote a tweet yes and I saw
that and I'm like oh no there's probably
a lot more and the streamers were
started figuring out sleep schedules we
start figuring out sleep schedules and
kind of just the immenseness that this
puzzle was it hits us and then again
when we were about 75% done with it and
we started the the slow drugging end
trail and we started getting in
thousands of pictures per hour we were
like this is just this is too big Satan
might actually be too big because there
was no way for us to take care of of
everything that was going on at once and
that's why we ended up having to be like
guys just just don't gather any more
data probably here like cuz I mean at
this point and I last question before I
give it back to you here cuz at this
point I mean you guys are compound all
is data I mean initially I'm assuming
you guys are using basic things like
Google Docs stuff like that this stuff
has to be putting so much stress on
websites and servers like that had to be
immense with all these people
contributing yeah go for it yeah I'm
gonna shoot that Rader as I core because
there's a story about that yeah let's
get to it let's hear it
so we started off with Google sheets and
that's where I started off with about
30,000 40,000 lines and and
so we're down a little bit and there was
only me and one of the paths and working
on this sheet at the same time oh it
wasn't there wasn't many of us and then
all of a sudden it just closed and then
we were late would close and then my
phone's going off and I'm luring it in
any attention and I'm receiving and
security alerts from Google telling me
that if I continue to use as many API
calls as I am they're going to disable
my account
you got to see something they started
shutting down share links so think that
we were sharing to access the the sheets
they were closing them down and because
they were receiving too much traffic
they started disabling the links in the
Sheep belt because there it was creating
too many HTML links Wow I'm parsing link
it started losing massive amounts of RAM
usage within Google Chrome um it yeah so
we had to then had to strip out all of
my scripts that I wrote and all of the
the AO learning that we had and host
that locally on a different machine and
then remote connecting to the sheep Oh
cause without like a 1 second delay in
process which wasn't much but when
you're dealing with 30,000 lines it's
it's annoying when you're scrolling down
the page and you're scoring quicker then
it can update the equation whoo Wow Wow
you broke Google good job like yeah that
daddy's tremendous cuz a lot of people
don't realize that how much stress that
would put on this day and they're seeing
that kind of activity they're gonna
automatically assume something
suspicious that it was a I get it to it
he said so now at that point you kind of
shift because now you have to do things
locally right and then you know the next
step then becomes from what I saw you
know I'll let you jump in I just got one
question um what I saw is that people
were getting a little upset that they
weren't getting that the people who
wanted to contribute
they were getting up said they couldn't
get that like real-time interaction so
it became almost like I have and
have-not kind of thing so like how did
you guys deal with that with people
without it like yo we want to contribute
but you guys are like hey we have to
protect what's going on here otherwise
we're gonna you know you know what
attacked my Google will crash down the
network with all the stuff we're doing
okay so I'll take this one um so my role
shifted as we got to the end of things
so
basically whenever someone wanted to
work with us right for some reason the
cat thinks that my direction to my disk
or DMS um so if they were if it was a
new idea that we could implement without
backtracking we talked to them uh in
regards to teams so every team that
reached out to us we reach back to them
at the end of things and I think I was
in six dis cords for for other teams
trying to kind of like I guess keep the
peace for lack of a better term we were
getting data in so fast and because at
this point everyone's data was already
combined together that means going
through duplicate data and trying to
find unique entries out of that
duplicate data well the way we had it
set up through a website we had a
website that had our CSV file on it
there were so many people watching the
streamers they could go to this website
check to see if their entry was unique
by searching for it and then send in the
unique image which is a which takes
basically a whole lot of work out of the
hands of our team right and when the
other teams are sending in their stuff
to us at the point we receive their
stuff we already have the pieces that
they're looking for because they exist
in our chat so it became to where we
weren't able to take in any new data
like I was saying before and that caused
a lot of tension within the teams
they're like oh well why aren't you
viewing our data and they tried to tell
them like no no your data has been
extremely helpful to this entire process
problem is we probably already have the
data mmm and and we want everyone to be
able to contribute to this but it comes
to a time where there's just so much
going on right it would actually hurt us
to put this data in and then try to find
and then the map screws up like the map
literally takes on amalgamations and
then find where data is wrong and and
then fix it and manually go through
everything it's just way easier to at
that point in time
grab the unique entries and it caused a
lot of disruption in the community
people thought we were withholding
information or storing information but
every time the map broke well why why
would I give you a map that has wrong
data entries in it and is all over the
place when I know you're going to use it
for pathing purposes right you're gonna
try to find a path I want to give you
the most accurate one that I possibly
can and so at the end of things there
was this whole free the map thing going
on in chat right hashtag
we're like we don't want to give it to
you until we have something to give you
I'm reading in a chat with with my art
team getting DM by streamers communities
because keep in mind I'm the lake at
this point the liaison but you like the
layers on you're just about to say and
I'm like listen as soon as I have
something everyone will receive it at
the exact same time as soon as the
website is is fixed and can hold our CSV
file or CSV files gonna be up on there
we're not withholding any information we
had to put out public facts on reddit
Wow I dreamed a QA stop yeah and we're
like it just goes to show you how
invested everyone was that you guys had
to go to these legs to really you know
you'll be the layers on and soothing the
community who really was the get about
chubby this is just enjoying all the
information so now you guys have been
awesome so far already let me we got the
point where obviously you're paying
peacekeeper up there either pretty much
the entire time and psyche wars over
there like nose to the grindstone I just
saw you would said and check you didn't
leave your desk or two days
did you sleep like okay so here's a
question yeah let's get to how much
sleep or lack thereof did you guys get
during this like basically one week span
so I was actually working during the
remaining five days the puddle a zoom
though I did two 12-hour shifts at my
job and and then went home and then
stayed up all night until I started back
day after I'm doing pazzo then what they
went home did another thirty hours then
on my days off sitting at my desk doing
puzzle work so and sleepy fat under its
own old fat sleepy panda story I'll get
Sleepypod the she did 4e to 45 hours as
well and in the same store because we
were on different sides of the different
time zones they're all there needed to
be someone from the very tiny berry
I hate saying the word quarks it makes
us sound like we were more important
that wasn't the case
that's the the tools that we were using
to amalgamate the data to do the check
finds do the all of this they couldn't
be left because as their spewing updater
the AI is learning from itself and if
you're not correcting the mistakes on
the the manual verification giving you
and it would never land so we got it to
95.6%
accuracy by the end of the the puzzle
where it could take the data without
looking at the picture and go that's
wrong well that's right
hmm there was always one of us away so
and ER and me kind of not v selection
just out of necessity
one of us was always awake during that
period so yeah I was at my desk two days
just didn't leave or the pizza sabi
death was drinking yeah and then got
four hours sleep but back
wow-whee so stories either give me some
stories alright so starting from day one
I got a total of 16 hours of sleep cuz I
calculated it my average bedtime was 4
a.m. my average wait time was 7 and I
believe and and and legs I was saying
like we need the problem was we were
needed and because we were needed we
would get to the point where we would be
excited right because everything was
chugging along at this beautiful pace
but we would also start to get irritable
and I think the biggest problem when
you've got a whole bunch of people
together and they're not sleeping is
eventually they're going to just want to
be quiet and do their own thing and not
be bothered and be irritable and so the
biggest fight in our team basically
throughout this entire process was not
to kill each other and to continue to
like support each other and give each
other the support we needed throughout
the whole thing because when you have a
whole bunch of people not sleeping
tempers are high a bit you're basically
whit's him like the whole like those
last few days you guys were just like
alright you good get your data and
alright let me alone I we had to do not
disturb channels Wow and then me
personally I'm in web dev right that was
like my my my channel thing my channel
name was web managers so I would chill
in that very very quietly waiting for
someone to approach me with a question
so I can tell them no and at one point
all of the streamers I'm just sitting
there minding my own business I think I
was actually streaming at the time
and just streaming working on different
things and I just hear it did it did and
I and I see whenever they move it's like
watching ants go into an anthill because
they go up one at a time because our
discord works and all of a sudden I hear
all these voices in my ear and I'm like
oh no they entered my channel started
pushing bounties because they wanted me
to decide bounties and and I actually
had to DM hub because when they were
done asking me questions and stuff they
didn't leave channel I'm like huh please
get them out of my room crazy there's no
other rooms for me let me hide so yeah
yeah it was pretty wild
that's intense man this Wow okay I could
I can't even imagine you don't say like
all the different layers the
complexities of each step of this
process and all the amount the hours and
stuff but what about other community
members like in general that um you feel
maybe kind of really helped out cuz I
know you guys like I said you guys
definitely a huge property obviously it
was definitely a lot more community
members involved as well
so like give me some standouts give me
some people that you remember a certain
moments had some great ideas or you know
even even just you know calm this the
the savage beasts which you know give us
some names out there
ah do you want me there was this a
couple that we work with we work with
the most and so I'm never remember most
people's names I'm gonna [ __ ] right
guys I've got a whole list right here is
that some shoutouts credit out
sleepy panda was pretty good well
amazing at being the day entry Frank was
streaming and was also really good at
trying to pull in new people up was
brilliant at kind of micromanaging the
freelancers or the people that just
wanted to come in for an hour or so and
help and and leave Regina was amazing at
kind of modding the chat and pointing
back to us the things that we were
missing gotcha
lyrics is the he slept for six hours and
it was the hardest six hours of my life
because I had to put out the graphics
sitting it over to me throwing it up on
this thing and I'm like I missed nearest
yeah he has a talent for that like yeah
he's a kibbutz he's so well done so well
continue can do you as I
our acetal was kind of also helping with
hop and getting all the the everyone
kind of organized and then the one that
I still think is the most important
because without it we would still be
used to bookshop and do it manually
you're using other tools that
potentially one as graphical when
vegetable to the eye is TJ with his his
map tools
if he hadn't created that that matter
software mmm-hmm
I don't think we would have been out to
validate as well so TJ's tool out at the
end create the bounty because it was
telling us it's the date we needed to
know to match up the pieces hmm which
calls the whole diamond five six fiasco
mmm it's explained that as I saw that a
couple times in chat too
yes stop in five six stuff but you just
talk about if you know you know yep
we'll just leave it at that
just like inside joke like we should
probably get through your questions okay
okay good I was like I mean this has
just been kind of part of it too so you
guys like just if you got any fun
stories about it to keep going in so I
mean I almost say imperious if mine no
go ahead
the so I actually have like a list list
oh let's go people alright so a huge
shout out to the streamers that worked
on this um I haven't given my like
official thank you because I've like I
want everyone on there you know um so
Chevy who was doing sheets well doing
stream and just he was powering through
like is his own sheet and filtering in
it and his his thing was so accurate it
was insane mom CB gray Evan half Evan F
actually saved my life during this
because there's a point where I was so
angry I couldn't I couldn't function and
I don't get angry but in ends I knows
this but it was like 30 minutes where I
was just like so angry and Evan pulled
me into laser tag with devil Bruin in
private matches and it kind of calmed me
down and relax Thanos great oh and his
video is incredible Frank who was all
over the place
glad who was just managing a crazy chat
collide OB katie-cat fami res stayed no
to rage ololo zero psychos vendetta Zoey
and then t-rex for the beginning portion
the community teams that we worked with
tours can army quarter crunch
and an Rix community team dingy team
raid secret vault explorers and then a
huge shout out to my team of course you
know yeah you had flame who was all over
the place during this and just kicking
out data like crazy hoplite Percy dough
Raz 765 explosives AC fat sleepy panda
bananas I have toes JP death blade the
people over in the other teams that were
kind of Debs
and working with me ebook Marsh Senate
and then hyper fuller who made the
original Excel spreadsheet we worked off
of my team of course nearest Regina tjs
I accepted I was like all teams so he's
all over the place Nick Serra who made
the original graphics Corbeau who worked
on some map stuff electrum whip Roboto
Yorktown and infinity and Steph was who
was finding unique entries between all
the spreadsheets and then of course the
the hundreds of thousands of members of
the community who came in and
transcribed with us and sat there for
long hours sacrificing their time to
help us figure this out obviously I
can't list all those names so if you
were involved with this project at all
if you submitted a photo if you
transcribed if you did any of that go to
ghost of Osiris comm because we have an
actual where you can enter in your name
and enter in what you did and the list
is already filling up with guardians who
were involved with this and and when all
the names are in in two weeks the site's
going to be archived and you're going to
see that giant list of already over
thousands of guardians who were
submitted photos did map pathing or
even just moral support like this is the
community's puzzle this is their puzzle
and we just were able to put it on a on
a graphic for them that's awesome I mean
shout-out to you guys for that because
you know a lot of a lot of content
creators sometimes wouldn't necessarily
do what you guys are doing right now
which is giving the credit to everyone
that was involved cuz it was a true
community effort we did we definitely
don't integral roles you two had that we
respected I love that you guys did that
so everyone gets their advancement they
see that like that's awesome so shout
out to y'all for that number one um er
the transition but I want I think you
had a question before I don't want to
interrupt your questions just keep it
going
we'll get through it okay you exactly I
know I know I we got to respect his time
um but I would being that we talking
about remembering people everywhere and
stuff you know obviously during that
period you know damage these guys they
came out with a statement and you know
as far as you know how this quest was
gonna be handled and you know initially
you said it was a marathon not a sprint
and we get into that end you know you
guys get into the to the finish line
you're getting the result and then you
know it was it was mixed on the ending
should I say and I guess the first part
is you know I know we'll get to the
reward but I want to talk about the
quest itself because as of right now
correct me if I'm wrong
e-bye reset the corners of time is gone
yep 20 minutes gone
yep right so we all agree I think we all
here agree at the last word that this is
one of the coolest things that's
happened that brought the community
together from a puzzle standpoint but
how do you guys feel about this going
away I need feedback on that let's start
with lasar was like
so
in a
nostalgic way I'm gonna miss it and it's
been a really really engaging puzzle
this I've always wanted to be more
involved for the Destiny community and
I've always wanted to go to destiny calm
and guarding on I've never felt like
but I'm just gonna go in it's just gonna
be people I don't know this then has
allowed me to meet people that I
actually really am excited to go and a
book I'm going and I'm gonna have an
amazing time and that's what that's done
for me is I've always been involved I've
never always been on the fringe and the
outskirts I've never really got involved
with puzzles at law but this is this is
this was my puzzle this was something
that I was my skillset this was no no no
I know I could do this I know I can be
involved I know that I can get this get
where we need to go I just need help and
if I can convince them that I can help
them then that's amazing and that's
that's what this buzzer did for me it
kind of brought me into the desk and
just gonna be can speak destiny
community and that's what I'm really
excited for okay that's awesome so it's
really cool we're going he's really sad
everyone doesn't get to experience the
corridors like we did
there's obviously loads of people
arguing the fact that people don't have
to run the quest any more but that
doesn't really bother me it's just the
experience of the the
I ran that final straighting that's 30
string all-time as I messed it up the
past three usually though
that's what people don't get to
experiences they don't get to experience
yes it's just another area weathers
general ads there but it's the fun of it
it's being involved in something that
the entire community spent nearly an
entire week trying to solve was really
exciting yeah why here either so my
opinion on quarters of time going away
is
this was an incredible community
experience a lot of people did not know
about this
because the seven days might have been
you know the seven days they took off
from destiny or maybe they were less
engaged with the game and didn't know
what was going on that being said
I I feel bad for them for those people
that weren't able to participate because
even just submitting a photo you know
it's it's being part of something bigger
than yourself in the Destiny community
the fact that the quarters of time is
going away
I personally I'm going to miss it
because I would love to later on sit in
them and just kind of reflect over
everything that happened because this
was such an amazing amazing thing um as
far as people not having to run that
dirty code
I it doesn't bother me because if if
they really don't want to be involved
with the community which is fine and
it's a totally viable thing mm-hmm
if you if you like doing your own thing
then you know what if they choose not to
run it then they missed out and
and it is what it is I'm not upset about
a going away I'm not upset about the
quest being sent to st. but I do feel
bad for them
that they aren't able to experience
something as amazing as this yeah um he
could let you go because I was going
right no it's like I know we got the
psycorps for just about five more
minutes no I know you gotta go so I just
wanted to kind of ask you you got
something he should explain Diamond five
six yeah believe so as your buddy gift
to us we're gonna ask like what is this
diamond five six and then I'm just gonna
get final thoughts and let you get back
to your world cuz yeah you jump jumped
in in the middle of uh sneak it away
from work so yeah so
by the end of the puzzle by we released
the 400 map um and said there was 540
left or 640 left to go we released the
map and we started getting mobile data
and we got to a point where we had about
hundred pieces left behind and all of
these 100 pieces were all in
like the Centers of another five for
another six so you could whack up
whether edges were going to be we would
realize at that point that all the black
pieces were just filler will work not
really good for anything
[Music]
but the ones would be the centers were
the ones that were building the route
that I thought we were following so I
filled in all of these fake lines on the
spreadsheet and that's where we were
getting our bounties from if you look at
about 2:00 in which we knew what the
edges look like we just didn't know what
the middle looked like no um Oh started
filling in all these of XI and I copied
a line down from further up the document
and pasted it in the middle of the fake
bounties and that included the center
being filled out as a diamond
and then refresh them up and bang Matt
was complete and the final piece that
was missing was diamond piece that I put
in before I had a chance to remove the
sensor icon but it then unfinished the
map so that people didn't think that was
the solution and one screenshot it and
it was shared and that was it that was
the solution that was up there so when
we were in Gladstone obviously in bad
server and I'm not bad on stream whilst
doing this and I'm sitting there and I
won't swear on your string because if
you do I'm sitting there and I'm
absolutely screaming everyone in the
channel going what the hell like who did
it it's wrong is why have you shared it
and it was correct so the the final
piece that sold the map was a fake
diamond five six the day after that
someone actually sent me a image of the
piece that we found so where we've
verified it it's really but yeah so
diamond five six five six was either
there fool naked ever mate or it was the
biggest freak I've ever liked the final
pass was almost finished by accident to
to a small point basically Wow oh yeah
but if if it was wrong then people would
have questioned any fad map or any
further recoup I don't see who's wrong
wrong the time in five six comes from
Wow Wow how well the pieces are in the
actual map like what's the final tally
5040 though factorial 7 as its bunging
yeah yeah make sense make sure they
budgie loves this sentence you die they
do Wow
bullseye core I know you gotta go so if
you're just gonna kind of wrap up let
everybody know where they can find you
and we want to thank you for being here
explaining your side of this puzzle and
I think the whole community hopefully
can thank you because they may not know
what you built to make this thing
possible but thank you very much for
explaining at least a little bit of to
us somewhat layman sometimes but
definitely getting in the mix of
everything you built to make this
possible and the whole community did it
but as like yeah thank you so let them
know where they can find you say hi give
you just a Twitter hello whatever that
may be so throw it out there
yeah on Twitter don't use it that much
so if I don't respond its apologies but
at cycle underscore in ing that's pretty
much it don't use any other social media
and may start I really want to start
streaming late one of the year so that
maybe maybe add a family on which they
only hear this and for now it's just
building instruments discordant Twitter
nicely played
didn't we make you get a Twitter during
this did you have one prior we made you
get one I had to make my death account
yeah listen you are a celebrity now Zach
to be on point would you Twitter game
people who want to hit you up they
wouldn't know who the algorithms the
supreme chic guru is you got it you got
a piece to the fans now man you saw raw
jokes is a big salute we know you got a
run but thanks for again sharing your
piece your involvement with it and like
I self even get you guys back on as well
love talk just actually see you at our
hopefully with some tattoos in the X
grams and okay time in five six do it
like DCP put it on your butt falooda
Zico man thanks again for coming much
appreciative it all up and we are back
as like we're had to run guys so thank
you very much for sticking with us we
were back for part two but ether is
still here and we got the two of us we
gonna jump into still a few more
questions on this thing cuz we got
either here he is he's got the time to
chat but design core was kind enough to
lend us an hour of excuse me hour of his
busy actual being functional day cuz we
kind of stole him from a little bit of
work but you know do what you got to do
but yeah like so I mean coming back to
this thing when all this stuff was
coming together don't ask just a couple
kind of specific questions we were
trying to get how did you guys start
dividing into Lake okay
so here's this I know you kind of said
you had like uh played you had like the
art team and like I know she was
involved in the you had Franken like
there were so many different people but
how did you guys start dividing in like
okay you guys are gonna be the streamers
we got the managers hidden people how
did people start getting into these like
this org chart of a quarters of time
team so I'm kind of curious how though
was it just that an assessment be like
screw it I'm running this part or was it
just more hey it's like you guys want to
kind of divide and conquer do these
pieces how'd it go well it's crazy
because looking at the entire thing it
was shockingly organic like and it was
kind of just something where you know
when I joined into the discord there was
just one channel and that was all the
streamers and then there was a channel
to pull them in right and then Perry
Seto who's actually a model on the
server we were like listen can we have
rooms because we had glads subscribers
have access to those rooms so we
couldn't necessarily like hide and talk
unless we were in a private discord call
but then we wouldn't be able to be
pulled in if we were needed with the
streamers so what Percy derp did is is
he made these corridors channels and
just it was just originally quarters one
course two quarters three and then it
was it was me hop and streamers
basically and then and then these mods
and I hopped in the streamer streams I'm
like listen cuz I had a Photoshop
template and I was making each of these
individual pieces by hand and I was like
listen I need people that know how to
use Photoshop and I need them right now
like I'm like there's no way I can do
all these puzzle pieces myself by hand
and so Chevy said on on his stream he's
like someone contact nearest get near
sover to ether and then
Regina was pulled in as well and because
she knew how to use Photoshop and was a
huge help in the beginning stages and
then when nearest popped into my DM
that's right
so obviously I'm a streamer and I have a
discord community and I'm involved in
Ali's a share his graphics every single
week so I knew who he was and as someone
who works in graphic design he was like
one of my the people I looked up to you
know I'm like oh I wish I could do what
what he does and so when he slid into my
DMS I freaked
hmm and he's like can I be on your art
team I'm like yes please come in too and
I'm like oh this is great like I've got
a team I can actually do this I might be
able to actually handle this because
it's probably only like a hundred pieces
mmm yeah
not even realized yeah about that not
even realize how big the scope of this
thing is and so originally it was just
the art team and then the the streamers
and huh and then it evolved over time
because I went to bed and I woke up and
all of a sudden there's new channels and
there's a data managing team there's a
team for just transcribing there's you
know a channel for bringing in people
that want to work with us and talking to
them and the hardest part was getting
other teams to trust us because some of
you guys may remember
I'll break and um the aftermath that but
in the I made sure when I talked to
every single person I said listen you
are receiving the map at the exact same
time as everyone when when a map update
was ready it went
boom streamers at the same time Twitter
at the same time these community diss
courts gotcha because I wanted to make
sure everyone was on the exact same
playing field and and knew they could
trust us with their with their data and
there was people that were open and
shared their data with us and and molest
them there were also people who took
their data and kind of just went like
this and then also took our data and
they're like we're gonna solve this
first oh and the thing is it's bigger
I've at the end they realize okay is way
bigger than some big guys we could do no
bands good because we were pulling in
the most amount of data it was just
easier for us to lock up these
spreadsheets because that was the other
thing to pair like why are you locking
your spreadsheets well Google thinks
were ddossing them and then someone will
take the link to our data go and grab
all the data and then the people who
stay up for four six seven days right
all of a sudden the work they did over
that six seven days is showing up in a
more complete form somewhere else mmm
just by someone who's not even working
just pulling data and trying it out and
I was like no I don't like that let's
just bring everyone into the TA this
let's kind of get our I've wanted
everyone to be involved with this and
that was kind of my goal this entire
time so I'm so sorry I forgot the
original question no no you pretty much
was I was just honestly curious how
people kind of fell into teams but it
sounds like it just it looks pretty
organic just okay think it's gonna
happen you woke up like okay now I've
got a data team we've got the streamers
talking like weather who's on sleeping
shifts and stuff like that it sounds
like it was just out of necessity more
than anything just because okay so we've
got okay we have thousands of these
things somebody's built a program for
this all right we need people managing
this website okay you got nearest in the
art team here doing these things couple
people talking between team streamers
working together and then as you say and
some people are trying to be that first
person not realizing it's better than
any first team could ever hope to do
because it's gonna take as you said
5,400 images or 5040 I'm sorry yeah 5040
images so make this thing and you're
only getting duplicates like how many
actual do you guys have like a random
number of how many total entries were
there out like duplicate included just
how many how many images you guys
finally get in total
okay uh hold on I'm gonna actually pull
up the numbers because I don't trust my
memory that's Mary you haven't slept not
cool yeah well I have sub now for the
record nice nice
uh I have definitely done a lot of just
passed out wake up don't even know I
slap you bird that say so
they only imagine not your place like
them to they are crazy so yeah it's like
it's yeah yeah I find it interesting
though while you're looking that one up
that we actually had a point where
Google's like hey this is not a good
thing like what are you guys doing like
you actually have somebody that scale
saying uh yeah you can't do this and but
people don't realize as well you're like
I don't want this spreadsheet to break
so I have to lock it and then people are
getting mad and you're like and there's
no way that communication King gets all
the people fast enough there's no way
you can get to all the people trying to
submit to be why is this locked we're
trying to help quit you know being this
type of person it's like we're we got to
like pull back on the reins a little bit
just to keep this thing alive and that's
I honestly didn't picture that you guys
actually had to get to that point that's
so crazy
yeah it was insane I'm so interested to
hear like the article a hidden fighting
way just like you know people thinking
they're gonna have some their own little
separate agenda not realizing how big
the scope is and that's the cool part
that it forced everyone to get together
it forced them to look at what you guys
are doing and say you know what but you
know let let's all collaborate let's all
pull from this singular resource cuz
yeah that that's funny yeah it was
insane I at the end of it I'm just like
why why are you guys not like mmm look
at this point I am gonna horde to do
justice by myself a community thing
let's just all do this thing together
and that was the hardest thing to like
get through to people because so many
people viewed this as a world's first
race
yes good point but that is absolutely
not
Bunji was like no no no no no they even
tweeted there's like there's no world's
first mmm-hmm and that was that was the
hardest thing I think for people to
understand is that it wasn't a race to
be the first person to solve it it was
gonna have to be an entire community
thing mmm
fair enough so I can't find the actual
numbers but I can give you an estimate
so we we received over 40k
Wow and and that was that was I think it
was actually way more than that hold on
you know what I can do to figure this
out right now just message message the
group oh there we go
and trees did I wish Zico was here cuz I
think he's got the actual breakdown no
that's still bomb I'm gonna it was I'm
over 40k yeah that's so crazy
nah I mean and that's that is something
that and this is when we were talking
last week actually on last word because
of where it was kind of in the point
where it was we didn't quite know the
scale we saw the pictures getting bigger
and bigger and I even said it to him and
I was honestly just like I honestly I
was like if it is room if you guys are
on the right path like I was wondering I
was like is this something to wear
because normally if they've done like a
smaller fireteam could solve this like
it was like hey a group of six if you
knew binary whatever it was like you
could eventually get to a point where
like a small group of people with the
right skill set could do this and I was
just like and I was honestly like
racking my brain I'm like either Bungie
took the biggest gamble in their
community which they didn't it paid off
big time it was awesome or they're like
there's an overthinking going and you're
not getting images that are really gonna
talk or something of that nature
right and when it finally got to the
point when I saw the the big chunk the
big rectangle finally like I was like
damn like they really went first human
they went for the glory and I was like
oh my god its scope st. yeah so it's
just the sale of this thing and mm-hmm
they expected it to be longer of course
but either way just the fact that you
guys were able to do what you did now
switching if you get an answer feel free
to tell us if you get that final number
yeah the reward so what you guys are
going through this thing while you guys
were in the middle of it before you even
got there there had to be talks in like
your discord things there hey hop like
what do you think this is gonna be or
what were the speculations what was
what was the feeling in the week of
flake no sleeping you're hallucinating
like what you guys think might have
happened what were all the feelings of
what was coming yes so uh just theories
in general we're very interesting
throughout this whole thing
at one point we actually thought for
example that every blank space might at
some point be a symbol and we might have
to wait for that symbol to come around
on that blank space ah dude who a
duplicate and and something transcribed
wrong but wooden regards to the actual
reward for this oh so we we knew from
the beginning
due to the date of mind voice lines
about the dialogue of say fourteen yes
so we knew that that was going on so our
theory of course as well as the rest of
the Destiny community we were all
sitting in a voice chat and we said you
know what it's Razorlight it has to be
razor lane or or odd death drinker dark
drink Georg Elser yeah and they're like
we're like it has to be that right
because there's no way it's Bastian like
those were the exact words said we were
like oh it better not be Bastian that
was only the process of elimination
black is when when that was stated me I
I thought Bastian was a pulse rifle
because I misread the information and so
I loved bastions one of my top ten
favorite words I actually have a list of
my top ten favorite words and and one of
them is the word Bastian and
I really enjoyed pulse rifles so I'm
like oh come on guys like it's not that
bad if it's fashion that's that's a okay
we're not realizing in my head it's a
fusion rifle and Houghton is a PvE
player primarily that's the worst gun
okay I agree and so once I found out as
a fusion rifle my heart just sank and
then when when we were doing the run and
we realized that the reward was fashion
like in the back of our minds we all
knew we all knew and was mashing we
discussed we just didn't want to admit
to ourselves that it was bashed we got
through with the final quest and and
there it was
and we kept our hopes up that maybe it
has a perk that just makes it not need a
charge time and now
no not so yeah we theorized about that
we theorized at one point we theorized
this was actually my theory if that the
the map was was top and bottom based off
of looking through the glass and then
looking up and seeing the thing so there
was also the idea at one point we were
like the maps three-dimensional and has
multiple levels we were talking about
possibly elevators being a thing it's
we've been over some crazy areas like my
brother came in at one point he looked
down it's like it cuz it has the major
hex in the middle and that everything
kind of tapers off and you're like is
this one big giant sphere that would be
another idea how you could literally
just start laying the pieces around a
circle and get him connect that that way
it was like oh that's gonna take a hell
of an art team some somebody sitting
there and just like a 3d render program
and just spinning this globe like how
the hell is this gonna work
at one point we thought as a bunch of
bang grams attached together
oh ho god I could see that though is
that so it's all over the game and it
has that yep I could definitely see that
shape in there as well so you have like
a three dimensional in Graham and then
like you could print this thing out with
a 3d printer that would be too funny but
Bungie if you hear this don't get ideas
no okay
I was like art working with 2d is plenty
with five thousand images we don't need
to start making 3d models of stuff like
somebody's out there with just CAD like
making crap like that
that would be too funny yeah that was
there a point of contention II you know
as far as the whole reward I mean yeah I
mean I'll be honest you know I'll jump
in yeah like it's your turn now you're
part of this thing now yeah I mean you
know the other day it's like this you
know I you know we've had this
discussion when last word as far as
these type of quests which is you had
you know Devils ruin which is very short
lore heavy you know with a little voice
stuff and then you have something like
this you know and my we talked about
this ad nauseam before my feeling is
both can coexist right I'm actually more
of a fan of the first he listened
because I got more of the banter from
say 14 Osiris and shacks but this was
cool because the entire community came
together and and seeing it on this scope
amazing but you know I was watching from
the outside cuz I'm I'm gonna let those
people who are smarter than me handle
this but I've got a watch right so I'm
sitting in I'm watching them okay
they're getting the you know at the end
this thing you know I was like like you
said I'm either night wow this thing is
way bigger in scope like this is not
like I'm like oh they're two days
they'll knock this out you know and then
I'm seeing this map and I'm like this is
insane right this is this is crazy like
wow like how deep is intricate this is
and then you know the day finally comes
and they solve and you're like wow now
the lower part with Sam 20 dialogue
which had been died in mind that we knew
fire I love that you're on saying we
talked about that and what that could be
a potential reality and Yatta Yatta
Yatta with your guardian
but they live reward and again you know
I think it comes down to this for me
you know the fact that we knew Bastion
was on the map the road map really hurt
a little bit because it's like damn if
we didn't know it I think it we received
better because you're like okay this is
cool unknown thing let's test it out you
know even if it wasn't that great you
still didn't know it was new is the
level of excitement right the first time
but knowing it it really struck and I
kind of struggled I know if you saw um
you know damages tweet explaining why it
was you know and he's like look you know
we had to let the season pass old ain't
no pass on buyers know whether or not
they're gonna pick it up by showing the
value of this specific season pass and I
get that to an extent from a marketing
standpoint but you could still say new
exotic without showing it you know and
then the second part and I know evening
you about to go in on this part is that
you know it comes a guy like me let's
just say I don't have time this week and
I don't do it right so I literally will
just go up to st. 14 you'll hand me
requests and he'll say do these other
things very short very easy and get
bastion and I'm like really like that
that to me you know I understand if it
can't stay for a limit I mean for a long
time but such a quick cutoff and quick
turn it's just a disrespect to the work
that you guys do in my opinion I'm just
being being real about it like I feel
this is something that people need to
experience so even if it can't stay the
whole season it shouldn't be like okay
the minute you solve it next week shut
it down it's a tough pill to swallow
because I think this thing kind of needs
to be immortalized as a destiny moment
and the last point I'll make you know I
know Luke's thing is you know you know
Luke Smith has come up with a director's
cut you know you should have been there
kind of thing but this level of
involvement this level of community you
know you have to respect it I think they
fumble the ball slightly with that you
gotta respect the community with that
and um if they're gonna make it
thing on the roadmap don't show it don't
name it just say secret excite exotic
quest you know and I think it would have
received better me personally I would
like vex about the class but hey you
can't get everything so let's care
Gjallarhorn but you know you can't get
anything but that's all I got to say II
I'm gonna give it to you where you at
with this we were we were texting during
a lot of this so I wanna know where you
at with it
so for me it was like I was kind of in
the same thing like when it started is
like okay so we got the first 19 symbols
and it sucked for me even just on the
first section just the first 19 I was
like okay so I had to stay off cool I
planned for this one I had to work at
five o'clock the next morning I'm like I
have to sleep I have to get up in the
morning I asked the work I was like I
went to bed at like 10 o'clock nope
ended up being about 11 so I got like
more maybe five hours of sleep woke up
check Twitter and I was like I haven't
set my alarm early cuz it was like time
wise like you guys are gonna be almost
done by the time I wake up and I
literally woke up and I was like I
didn't have enough time to run it but I
was like oh it solved wait there's more
and then I was like I'm at work like
every break I get him like look at my
phone seen what's going on with
everybody and then I start to see how
big it is and that's where I was like
you guys like I want to ask I'll give a
couple questions for you ether when I
get back
bu-but it was like I got to the point
where I was like I ran through notes
just like all right because we have the
19 hours
at first were like okay we know these
are gonna be 19 hours there's no real
way to rush this can't do anything
faster in that interim I was sitting
there streaming that night and I was
like all right so I'm gonna do this
stupid thing of when you go into maze
you always go left just to see what
happens and I was like I was like all
right so I took hex every time and my
unfortunate bad luck that I picked that
one first
I made a loop back to that original room
in 14 doors and I was like wait a minute
how's that like that's really small and
that's why when I was wondering if you
guys had over thought cuz I was like no
then I was like okay let me try the next
symbol and it was clover and I went 30
clover doors without a repeat I was like
it's gonna be a lot bigger than I
thought cuz you start doing the math of
like 5 times 5 times 5 times 4 times 3
times 2 times 1 and I was like and then
if you take the types of rooms with and
without lasers electric floor I'm like
there's like 925 or even more rooms that
you can have in this whole thing else
like there's no way in hell I'm gonna
find all this just see if I could like I
was trying to see is like I have all
schlund you a graphic just so you can
see I got bored and Photoshop was like I
was taking an image of what it looked
like so it's like okay so it's the tree
room with lasers and then around the
corner of each room for like a station
just like 1 2 3 4 5 in Photoshop I was
like time in clover hex snake whatever
and then I would draw a path going from
clover to the next one I was like can I
get another connection path and I was
like this is just in the first 19 hours
and then I saw what you guys did wrong
yeah 72,000 wrong rooms it's stupid
number of wrong rooms it's great okay I
was like after I did my first attempt
it's like all right I put my brain
through a little bit just for fun on
that one and I saw what you guys were
doing it's like all right now I'll just
help do images in that type of thing but
even just my effort in that just to see
like mess around in corridors just to
mess around in that 19 hours I was like
I was toying around in there I was like
seeing what you can do how many wrong
places you could go the effort that
everybody in the community put together
and then literally it was you guys
solved it Monday and it wasn't even
Tuesday that we had that tweet saying
hey it's gonna be gone and I was like
whoa whoa like it was late
I understand season activities that I
want stuff to be there hey you're gonna
be there for a little bit
vex offensive was three weeks long you
guys saw you guys solved and it's gone
faster than nice offensive was even or
the final assault was even here
mmm so like that's too damn like I I
understand people like hey why would I
go through the 30 piece puzzle I was
like to experience it if you have the
season pass if you're in here at this
moment it could collapse at the end of
the season and I could understand hey
mercury is gonna do whatever it's gonna
do we don't know how things are gonna
end we have three weeks on the roadmap
but nothing we don't know where it's
gonna end but at some point it should be
still be a chance to be experienced I
mean if you take things like whisper
take things like zero hour you still
take outbreak original and destiny one
you take those types of things like you
had to still go through outbreak in yeah
you had to put in the puzzle pieces but
you still had to go put in the puzzle
pieces stand on this one
get your codes you still had to do it so
like somebody hit me like hey what's the
thirty room code okay go run it they
would say still I think personally
should have to run the thirty room code
to see I agree play I agree and just as
you're running through like oh crap
because I like to understand the level
of the intricacy that could help them
like wow because let's say you're
running it even though you know it but
if you mess up like our man like I got
to do it need to understand before I
give it back that either what about
where do you stand with Bastion on that
map and bash back I got I need to know
where yet what the hell for me I was
like we've had multiple discussions as
about this but when it comes to exotics
for one there's really starting to get
watered down where they don't feel like
they said it before a while back it was
like we want exotics to feel exotic you
and I said that like the first year of
this podcast was like that exotic title
if you're gonna make it like that yellow
box it needs to feel exotic right now
literally you open your first season
pass box on the first date BAM here some
exotic like the effort to get it isn't
there right right then you do something
like this and make it this really
extreme thing and it's the same thing
that's not the road map I think is an
issue for me because the road map is
this puzzle was not on the road map so
don't put the reward on the road map you
could be like and you have three you
like even if devils ruin is like a
simple quest you know what's gonna start
that day by that ones on the road map
I'm like just
you know be like oh you know what would
it be a January just a question mark a
literally a box that just says January
and it's just a question mark we don't
know what it is we don't know what the
guns gonna be and it could have been at
least it looks gorgeous and if you knew
if you know you hundred-percent know
when you start the season that this is
gonna be tied to this insanity community
puzzle take the picture off the season
page so we don't know it's they're late
and I know people are gonna day to mind
but it was on the calendar and we
expected it the whole time and for me it
was just it was however good the gun
could have been mm-hmm we knew it was
gut what was coming we saw the little
lights half a second preview clip of
like the animation of a firing in the
season preview video and then by the
time we got it I was kind of like just
the wind just same as you guys like the
wind was just like taken completely out
of my sails by the time this whole
process is done I roll over Friday
morning or Monday morning I'm like uh-oh
like it was they saw there's the reward
I was like yeah a classic for people
rudl yeah let's get this gate door this
way I gotta go okay you have to
look at it right as the previous puzzles
we've had so far in IOB labs obviously
you can still go into that room and then
do the final puzzle and fight all those
bosses and get the emblem in the ghost
right it's it's a good reward for the
experience that happened with the puzzle
and and you know there's nothing like
that four corners corners does not have
even with sending bash in the same 14
and then the players can get it I'm
almost glad corridors of time is closing
because it is an experience that other
people who didn't do go through this
entire puzzle think they don't get to
experience quarters of time mmm which
I'm okay with
I'm going to miss corridors of time
because of the hours that I said in
their days I said and there um but but
it does close it off I think what Bungie
needed to do was to have the people that
ran it in the first 24 hours receives
and receive an emblem or if they can't
run through it the first 24 hours I have
it have something where they have to
fight a boss I think a boss fight needed
to be at the end of that 30 path I think
you had to run through the 30 path fight
a boss and then you get the weapon core
like the nine thing the dialogue and and
everything was good but I think what
needed to happen was you need to have a
boss fight so that would leave it open
for people to later run that do some
crazy boss fight and receive the weapon
core and and be able to go about Bastion
that way the fact that it was sent
straight to st. 14 hurts the gun itself
which I have now used
in a legit last wish run ran through all
last wish using only bastion for boss
damage I did garden of salvation only
bastion for everything except final boss
and the gun itself is not bad it's and
of course I bought the decoration for it
I think I think that it's gonna be very
weird when the 28th no 28th comes around
and it's not there um I wonder what the
effects that we have on the timeline I
wonder what Bungie cuz you know Bungie
sitting in room right now being like how
the heck do we fix this because so many
people are upset over this I'm glad I
went to same 14 because people that
didn't experience quarters of time in
those 7 days aren't gonna be able to
experience corridors of time which I'm
okay with I'm going to miss that I
however the quest itself to get it the
dialogue the lure to it is incredible
you know lore behind the actual weapon
if you if you look at the lortab for it
if you look at the thing that gets put
in your inventory is phenomenal it's
right up there with top level Bungie mmm
I'm just curious to see how this gun is
going to factor in over the rest of the
season and right lead to our eventual
demise
whether it be in this timeline or
another one right what do you feel about
now that you obviously it was revealed
it was on the roadmap and then at that
moment then Bungie says ok the rest
community they you know you go and get
it you know do you do you think that
maybe it would listen to blow if they
there was also an additional if they're
gonna remove it if they add like an
additional part of the quest or a
catalyst or something else to kind of
ease that blow do you think that could
have kind of hoped out oh absolutely I
think I think if they had some sort of
catalysts that evolved an activity
regarding the quarters of time that
would be
if if they took orders of time which
obviously so much of the community has
poured their heart into and later on
bring it back as a zero hour type
mission where you get in emblem or the
catalyst at the end I think that would
be incredible that would my you're very
very good at my eulogy end and mudgy you
can steal that idea for me please don't
hear like gonna buy like that but an
emblem or go shell attach to this would
have been extremely nice and and I've
talked about that before um but in
regards to the catalyst I want to see
some people do the type of work that we
did it seemed justified to member thee
you guys went level 6000 likert well you
know power level 9000 you guys went
crazy for it so to have somebody
literally walk up to Saint and this is
where I have the issue to is like if I
was literally on vacation for two weeks
I would have missed the entire time
thing within eight like three months
season pass like white I guess my issue
is like I understand it could leave even
if it was like maybe it's a month and be
like it's starting to destabilize we're
getting close so like but - it just
feels so short and confined for time for
when it went alive - when they're
cutting it off right that was that's my
issue for as your same way for people to
experience the boss fight I would love
to see one of those wouldn't we went
through and we got Zeno fades the boss
fight in the end like that was its own
room not a big I mean not saying
anything in this game is easy to develop
but they have the rooms what if you went
through and you're like okay so there's
like maybe two bosses you got two fights
you might actually have to bring a
second person cuz it's maybe two
something like the idea of a boss fight
would have been really cool for the
catalyst and emblem a ghost literally
any of the cosmetic stuff they throw at
us for doing crazy things like you do
the Niobe labs puzzle you get a damn
emblem most of the time and you're like
I can't even get that for this
we went 11 through and like even just if
you did type in the 30 code you don't
get you do get the weapon but there's no
thing that other people are gonna get
the weapons there's nothing saying you
did the 30 code I guess that's one
that's a valid point
right there that's fat I don't even
think about that he's right because
everyone can get that gun so it's not
really a memorial of the event mm-hmm I
mean at the very least the the ornament
should be given to those who yeah you
don't you're right it almost should be
like a a regex claymore situation
remember when that like they had like a
separate you know ornament or whatever
it is something to significantly signify
like look this was done through
corridors of time you can never get this
this group is specifically they adored
it and this is their reward for doing it
and you got one week and until your
point eat it is weird because when they
said about you know those moments that
are not gonna last long but then what
they told us it would last throughout
the season so again in defensive Bungie
we don't know how they're going to
change and there must be some reason I'm
hoping why corridors of time must leave
right now like why does it leave right
you know this next girl coming with I
hope it's a very good reason but you
know it that's the part I struggle with
because I would we were told that the
season things would kind of remain in
the season that like oh in two weeks
that it's gone and then that's it kind
of dig so yeah
yeah it's been amazing puzzle and work
that they did and then it's just like
the the final five yards of this entire
100-yard dash was a little a little bit
of a stumble in the end just in kind of
the final execution the move the like
lack of acknowledgement or some type of
specific thing to say you guys did
amazing stuff maybe it's not here
forever but if you did this you've got
it to take with you as opposed to
everybody who can you know basically
trip into a gun never having to see the
corridors of time it's just you I feel
like they're taken away from well
hundreds of literally hundreds of hours
of streamers and more sleep loss than
probably should have been between a lot
of people and it's just kind of a weird
feeling at this point they should get a
rayj give y'all something
eat eat thank you listen there's a
petition they got need a special shirt
with a special code just like they do
every other anxiety if you went court at
the time you put your 777 in and you get
that shirt you guys killed him I mean
people weren't getting sleep yeah this
was crazy this was like algorithms and
algebra and this is this is real out
here well I hate to say this but I mean
it is it is classic Bungie oh yeah at
the very very end of something whether
it be the season or whether it be
there's just this
and that's it going down hmm
then it stops halfway down the hill like
that's it that's been been fine and I
think part of that has to go with how
hard the team gets pushed to put out
content but I I think I think that is
100% what is because it could mean is
like nothing to do there's nothing to do
there's nothing to do and and then
bungees like okay we got a come on guys
what have we got ideas Roundtable let's
do this and and then they're like okay
well we we figured out the whole story
of this event thing and how are we gonna
finish this off with a bang
boom one didn't know and and I think and
then they don't think about the you know
longevity or like the what comes after
they're going moment by moment you know
you look at their calendar and it's
individual moments not in a calendar
that caused this chain reaction across
the calendar but when you get to the end
chain reaction it's just kind of and
abrupt and and that's it yeah he says
this Sopranos final finale ending of the
shadow keep camp yeah dick the thing is
I think you nailed it and and this is
what we've been saying on the last where
for a while I think as much as we love a
free and independent Bungie this is kind
of this stuff that bite it's gonna
happening we're starting to see happen
without of Vicarious Visions without a
high Moon Studios without an activision
it's like you know they don't they got
these great idea and like you said law
wise this was amazing now lore wise
they're killing it because this is where
I've always complained about things law
wise are in the best place it's ever
been that's just now finishing it and
driving it home right we had that issue
with undying mind you know saying you
know we now is this that it's like it's
like just that that continuity to make
you feel satisfied at the end and go you
know what
that's what I'm talking cuz literally if
they do all this stuff we would be
praising them from high heavens we'd be
like this is the greatest thing ever oh
my god and it's little things we're
asking for right now so if these little
things that they can't do it has to be
in my opinion of resource bin and then
kind of like on to the next on to the
next on to the next and you know you
just hope that I don't know if there's
another TV come in or you know how this
ever first money that we're giving
something can can can help out you know
kind of thing but I think you have
nailed it yeah so as we as we look at
the roadmap now the 28th is empty
because we have that already and then we
get to the fourth of the empyrion
foundation and then the sundial now I'm
gonna take crimsoned days out of there
because that doesn't matter for this
discussion of lore and PVE and stuff
it's happy Valentine's it's short-lived
but you have I mean it is it's not the
longest thing in the world so you have
from February 4th with the Imperium
foundation and II know Tom as the last
scion don't not entirely sure how that's
gonna work but we literally have from
that lunch five weeks until the end now
they told us about vex offensive final
assault grant that went over really
poorly because it was just literally
rescreen a boss and I know what that's
giving it not enough credit but
basically it's almost the same damn room
mm-hmm in all of your discussions in
this as well did you guys ever get to a
point or even just you yourself of what
is the foundation and what do you think
can wrap this season because they give
you a puzzle without the you know happy
ending how do you get to the end of this
season and how do you think about it I
was like how do you into this season and
not and feel where do you think they can
either kind of wrapping where do you
think this one leads since you're kind
of in the mix of all that stuff
yes so empyrion foundation was
definitely something that came up in
discussion while we were working on this
puzzle because as destiny to players we
like to hope for the highest when it
comes to bungee right away so at one
point we assumed that the whole Imperium
foundation project because when you are
following a natural train of thought
things just complete themselves so when
someone mentioned Imperium foundation to
us while we're doing this puzzle we're
like oh no what if it's you deposit
fractal line and the piece that you saw
in the puzzle gets posted on this giant
map for everyone to see which mind you
would have been the perfect way for
Bungie to get everyone involved without
having like power heads emerge right
then the easiest way would have been to
have a giant map on the wall so even
solar wind solar players could do it
giant map on the wall and then you go
you you view your thing and then you
have to deposit fractal line in order to
put your puzzle piece on the map you can
see this map filling in real-time mmm
amazing by the way that is what we
assumed the empyrion foundation was was
where you deposit fractal line and then
this pops out so at this point right
then we also considered the missing
Forge so as as you guys know the running
theory is that the old Russia Forge is
somewhere lost in on Mercury inside the
quarters the time and inside and on the
infinite forest and from that Forge
so we assumed like the beacon was light
the Forge right and that there was some
weapon attached that we didn't quite
know about yet but then when we got to
the end and and we saw the tomb like
that that idea was shattered of another
Forge coming amount on Mercury which
would be cool if they released a Forge
on each plant in every season with a
puzzle like this I think that would be
great and it would give us access to two
weapons outside of the season
but so yeah and we we had a discussion
after the entire puzzle was completed
about what is Imperium Foundation right
we have no clue
we are absolutely as lost as the
community is I'm hoping the only way
that they can finish this how its strong
for this reason is having empyrion
foundation because because they're
really good at eluding to mysteries
right yes yes so the only way they could
have this work is eluding like if they
alluded to the fact that maybe the guard
Ian inside that tomb is not us
right let's say it's someone who
sacrificed themselves for us
mm-hmm let's say you know st. obviously
reads off that touching memorandum right
so it can't be st. in the box but what
if Osiris gave up his life and that
would be an easy way to add Cyrus fan
Osiris fan where you go you gonna start
with me earrings for my man but there's
okay I'm gonna let you theorize but
continue pay like ridiculous more like
fanboy but if he had to do something I
mean he's trying to protect a sacrifice
his life to protect us before right we
saw it in the know I'm forgetting the
name of the season but the curse of a
cyrus source
oh that's literally what it's called
right there that was extremely well done
and and I think Bungie with st. brings
in this very real tangible idea of
sacrifice right we never see the people
in the tower that were protected think
about it we go out to all these planets
and we are protecting them but we never
see the impact on the tower on the
people and st. was a way that we could
see that impact that's why I got more
emotional during st. scenes than I have
in in most of destiny's history yeah yes
and and it allows us to quote-unquote
walk among the people and see I agree
and that the only way they can
successfully end this is they're going
with this whole idea of song you we see
Shaq sing
goodness sakes um would be so bad to
show the people of whatever we're doing
with the empyrion foundation isn't
focused on other Guardians if it was
focused on the people of the tower we
deposit this frack delight and we're
building up this defense of the last
city right um where eventually we create
this impenetrable shield around us and
then once again like a Titan bubble and
once again protect the city from all
outside forces and then have Saint
become the speaker or something and then
most of your second laces himself for us
that would be stop stop with that stuff
with hey that would be an absolute
amazing ending for the season because it
would create a tangible feel knew the
work we do as a guardian and I feel like
with crucible and us going and killing
other guardians and and we we don't
realize mortality as Guardians we don't
look at ourselves and think well what if
our light went out and we never rest
again we we don't think about what our
guardian goes through having to die and
then be revived every single time we saw
it in the zoo valid trailer in the
beginning of Death Ray trailer yeah but
but since that there's no grasp on
mortality at all in this room and I
think bringing people in saving people
like st. 14 seeing this dialogue about
the impact of the tower I think that is
what Bungie needs to end a season is
sacrifice what makes the video games
stand out emotional sacrifice no whether
it be us
becoming mortal for a moment like maybe
our ghost is is down or something
mmm becoming mortal for a moment to save
our fellow mortals oh yeah oh yeah I've
alluded to exactly what you talked about
you know during the whole dialogue of
how ballsy would Bungie be if they allow
this future to happen right now my
theory was just that maybe they wouldn't
do it as soon and it seems more of a
precursor to destiny 3 because in my
opinion they'd have to explain cuz you
know damn well when dusty 3 start we
ain't gonna have our guns [ __ ] have our
exotic so they're gonna have yeah
there's gonna be a reason that they
can't blow up the tower again we already
did that with it you know it with your
color but with God but um you know I do
think it's an awesome way basically
going down your path of sacrifice and
what it means to be a guardian different
I think that's an awesome way to start
that state so I love that idea the key
with this like you said - it's gonna be
how they transition this season to the
next what empyrion foundation actually
stands for you know there's a lot of
theories out there you know yours
included is far also in reference to
this being a beacon for Guardians I've
heard things of that nature
you don't obviously I'm a PvP guy you
know I would like some form of trials
with saint's leading in you know
that would be nice I mean I don't I'm
under the I'm very convinced that trials
is coming back next season yeah think
about it talk right cuz talk Bastion no
longer exists on the 28th right the only
reason Bastion would be pushed up in the
calendar mm-hmm is if they needed to
push that out quick which it is an EVP
type weapon mm-hmm if they had to push
that out quick to drop something else
that week could probably see the stuff
all around st. right I know he's covered
in like you know vamp blood brother
vamps like threw up in the hangar
because it let's let's talk about it
right at the end of the day they knew as
much as we give them bunch of crap for
the way they handle the end they had a
window as to when they think the
community would solve this they put it
on the map now it's released so if
you're releasing it this early now to
the general public ahead of that that
blocker you must have something in place
so I would love it to be what you say
yes oh then it's all forgiven oh you put
trials at that spot don't you worry I
won't forgive and forget quickly without
exercise but I do feel something has to
happen in that place cuz what's the role
maybe after the 28th what's the next
thing
so bastions on the 28th we know that's
like yeah February 4th Imperium
foundation is free to every single
destiny player so no season pass
required no shadowing required just have
to have the game which is that's weird I
know they have access to the obelisks
per se so they could write do that but
they don't have access to the sundial
same day on the 4th is also inna tom
Oblivion's triune and he I always
wondered about too because when you look
before we had a hollow voice he was void
sky piercer was art and then we had
solar for the sun-eater and then II know
Tom's the slate forth and he's just late
monochrome he's basically gray and black
he doesn't have anything specifically
like saying hey this is my affinity or
whatever he is for type so I always
wondered that's why I always thought
when we saw the corridors of time the
first time we might be dealing with him
in there cuz it is that time where
basically it's devoid of color when
you're going through the coursers of
time black white and gray and nothing
else but monochrome I thought he would
be involved in there
obviously I'm ultra wrong because we
don't seem to be going back unless it is
like a because I mean somebody who jumps
into the season right now even if
corridors of time clothes could still do
the same mission they just want to
explore it openly but listen at least
that's facts no yeah but here's the
thing
a there's got to be a reason why
corridors of
time cannot exist right now why next
week must it go there has to be a
gameplay programming reason because it
really doesn't make any sense it really
does it you know there's nothing more
wise that should mess it up right so
it's got to be something made that plan
that's gonna take place in that space or
you know like this got to be something
all right will be where they want to
keep it special for the community that
spent that time they don't want anyone
else like like a limited time okay were
you there for quarters of time kind of
deal no I think it a shorter window we
might see them trying to give back to
the community like it might not have
been planned to pull quarters a time but
they saw the community were like this
isn't special enough this wasn't limited
enough for us so that might be the
reaction to that I hope it's not and I
hope they're pulling it because they
want to use the space to test a zero
hour like mission mm-hmm
but I for like later in the season
launching for a different weapon
hopefully mmm but I I don't think that's
the case yeah which they you know I was
like I mean it going away seems weird I
mean the people who come into the end of
the season still could technically go
get past the end they just have to do
the other quest and go save st. and do
it so it's they're just the whole you
know Tom with the like the last Sion I
don't quite know what to expect their
Imperium foundation all we see in the
picture is the entrance to the you know
infinite forest but outside of that we
have a picture of that but if it's like
when you zoom in on the picture you're
looking at an infinite force that has no
opening it's flat weather there's no
it's like it's not even open yeah right
so again no idea Flitz some people have
wondered like are we gonna reset mercury
to like the past one is actually nice
are we gonna whirring it and completely
change mercury like when this season
ends the sundials lake goes through this
crazy rips out brakes and like whatever
timeline mercury is set in that planet
is just
in a different place like I don't mean
in trust me I'm not a lord guy so I'm
not I'm talking out of my butt so if you
got something good so so looking at the
same picture that you were referring to
so hypothetically here hmm mercury we
know there's mercury past mercury
present mercury future right room and at
any point it can transition between
these well we've already seen it be
stuck on mercury past the season here's
my opinion would you think I think
mercury is going to be stuck on mercury
future but if the future that exists
without us hmm so us depositing fracked
align is our way of shifting it back to
the correct timeline hmm and keeping
basically the timeline intact as we
broke timeline with quarters of time oh
we just we just did that we just
completely broke the timeline
um Bungie has stayed at that so if we
completely broke the timeline and you
got mercury stuck in this mercury future
what impact we already know that cabal
are trying to change the outcome of the
red war in the past mm-hmm so what if
they do
what does that future look like so you
can see a future mercury but not covered
in vex potentially something else
yep and since mercury exists outside of
the natural order of timelines right
you can 100% have a future
mercury taking place on all of mercury
because it is a giant vex construct
interested that's interesting to do is
interested if it's interesting like that
never see two weeks should be quite
interesting we gonna learn it we got we
got crimson days moving past that I was
like the day I I'm very curious how they
handle the final three weeks because
they told us about the final assault and
then they got the feedback on that which
was like it's just a boss so I'm
wondering they left it open for a reason
still wondering what that one's gonna be
but we're cuz now we have you know you
know Tom somebody's saying you know Tom
could be taken I was like that's the
other way you'd be monochrome but either
way whatever he is it's still five weeks
from the next week is crimson days and
you still have three weeks there is
something we don't know and I think
that's it and that's the biggest
question of we have no clue how the
seasons gonna wrap it right now we're
all kind of like uh is it how it's gonna
go we don't have a clue and it's kind of
it's weird to be wondering what truly
like I don't even know what the hell's
gonna happen after the fourth like hey
deposit your five thousand fractal line
whatever that number is and then I don't
know if it's gonna be as your say in a
community effort to like try and fix
mercury from being like completely
broken is there gonna be an immunity
tally like we did with the Mars
community event or is like this number
of night falls in the track and hey the
community has entered you know seven
million fractal line we need three
million more to go for that magic or
maybe it's seven seven seven seven who
knows it's a buncha number probably but
however you get there like when that's
done what else is good if you're a P if
you don't play PVE pvp what is literally
else going on for the season fine login
deposit my five years and then I'm done
like that's a month that's weird so I'm
very Scott there's no question you can't
be at the crimson days and that's it
laughs that'd be like well you've got
you got season of redacted around the
corner I mean I know we're not quite
there yet but we don't we have no clue
what that is
versus dawn we kind of you you can see
it on the season pass and that's how we
kind of got word of that um we have
absolutely no idea what redacted is and
because we have no idea what redacted is
we have literally no idea how the
seasons going to end
exactly even you backtrack that and
assume they're going to wrap it up in in
three weeks right at in those three
weeks they have to end the season they
have to have saint-14
leave or they have to have um the
sundial shutdown they have two things
all the timelines
and set up the story for the next season
so you know something has to happen at
that time there has there has to be a
transformative moment a huge fan for
like you said you do they like turned
out not gonna exist you know there has
to be you know what the fate of saint-14
as a regular NPC you know there's a lot
of questions obviously Osiris doing
Osiris stuff and going back into the
tower or vile activity is not gonna be
there what is he gonna be standing by
yep again that's why it has to be
transformative I mean what all I would
say is I would hope that it's something
on the scale of dreaming city when we
didn't know right and then it's like wow
this cycle is something that's happening
and now a whether it be with Mercury
itself
driver saying and it's so transformative
and now this now peels in to the next
season and we get that name because of
what has happened on Murphy like murkly
completely I think you order somewhat
maybe all you get my mind working I
think it is something huge here because
like you said those these two major
characters something has to right now
things are going to well st. back some
got that sub Cataclysm gotta happen it's
a big stuff we've ruined for us for a
little bit to set up the next season
well I know you're getting close to
about two hours pretty light there's
patch notes and stuff come and you guys
can check what's out there that's
nothing too major but just as we get
towards the end of this I mean is there
anything else I mean ather you've been
awesome to have on thank yous I cornered
you for racking and them secretly from
your phone in the middle flake seems
like whoever it is yet is I'm here in
spirit but yeah it's just there anything
else for your experience of this
anything else you want to see just I
mean were you sitting right now in the
world of destiny and like you know how
are things looking for you and I mean
are you active if like if there is that
big break are you taking a little
breather you're gonna sleep for just
like four days in a row like what do you
what are you gonna to be doing for a
little bit here coming up
so ever since searching over to PC
season of The Drifter I have not stopped
I destiny you soon there we go
because it was xbox pray oh it's really
interrupt you for a sec yeah go ahead
them them frames yeah how you deal with
them friends that field of view is my PC
I got a ended up in a period of two
weeks getting more tram score that I had
an Xbox oh mags because of allergies and
and and it just I can't I played David
so I did day one garden run and because
I love the day one whole thing and the
next day I tried to help some Xbox
players get it cleaner
whoo yeah you right of kindness you were
doing the Lord's work to talk to the
lowly folk of all don't you just notice
it is so it's it's like you're it's like
you're in a dream and sleep-deprived at
the exact same time when I'll be doing
the rest of the season of course I will
be grinding away it's been extremely
easy to get this seal um I already have
only all my pinnacle weapons I already
have all of my emblems my whole
collections complete for this season I
am just
hoping for more I'm gonna be rating
that's what I'm personally going to be
doing the rest of the season helping
people through that haven't been through
I think one thing that I can say about
this puzzle is one it guys to compute
the whole community height about
everything with each other yeah
and that's extremely important because
so many times we're stuck into the idea
of three-person fireteam right you got
dungeons you've got strikes you've got
9-month we're stuck into this idea of
okay I just need two friends and and I
see rates being more active now in just
a week after more Rick more raids are
being run I see this excitement in the
community to reach out to each other and
and I think that Bungie needs to
absolutely have events like this in the
future
and Bungie III after this whole
experience I have so much feedback like
nice please reach out to me I would love
to talk to you about this to the summit
yeah ends the it makes me hyper Guardian
Khan because this will be my friend yet
or anything I'm just slightly worried
about the expenses but I'm like you know
what I'm gonna do this I don't even care
and I've got enough people like Airbnb
and stuff like yeah there's exactly four
ways than the resort resort school but
yeah it ain't cheap nowhere Airbnb is
definitely where I'm looking
no the as far as the future of destiny
moving forward from just this puzzles
point of view mm-hmm I see it being
extremely positive but extremely scary
at the same time because Bungie has the
ability
to bring the community together like
this
absolutely can they keep doing it is the
question
yeah there's no doubt mama I think you
know I forgot who I was talking with and
um the person I thought was more of a
hardcore and Maemo per shot is dizzy he
was this Irish not dizzy and he's
hardcore mm oh and he's like look man
you know this is what mm oh let's do you
know these are these type of grand
scheme community moments and I just
think it's all this is dipping their
toes in it getting from their seeing
what works seeing what people like
getting it collecting the feedback that
kind of stuff I think this is definitely
direction they're going and again think
about this we've said this before he if
they just nailed the finishes of these
things right in these transitions right
we didn't have a raid a dungeon no
significant pinnacle PvP activity but if
all these things were just you know
ironed out with a little cherry on the
top the way we wanted it we wouldn't be
complaining any because we it's done so
well right the lore so well the
community building is so well so this
all close to perfection with this little
model if they could somehow get enough
resources to just iron it out we'd be
all right we'll be all right and I'd
know the feedback they see you guys you
know and hopefully the week we get you
we get you down to that summit so you
give them that feedback that they need
to hear because to see you guys she shot
this you know I'm sorry core as well you
know do what she did and bring the
community together and that kind of
stuff is next-level that that's why
people go crazy for this game yeah
that's why it's it's just this
insatiable meet me and II we met at a
Guardian card because it and as a result
this podcast was born we this is like my
brother now like you know say because of
this game like that how crazy is that
that that's the the power of destiny
Alyssa will bugs you like the bugs you
guys built during or solving this thing
you're gonna be like you're gonna be
talking with the other be like they know
who you are
like that's that's the food you walk up
Guardian can be like dude and you'll be
doing that to like 50 people now when
you go there like you're gonna have more
fans than you know we have a matching
tattoos
you gotta get relocation sir you gotta
get flu got we gotta pull out we got to
take the pig we gotta pull up and you're
definitely gonna see that this is
awesome it's good stuff they they're on
that they're on the right track yes I
just just smooth those landings put a
little cherry on top give us a little
dessert finish it right I'm good to go
it's been amazing and as you said it's
like we're to the point where it's like
they're they need to iron out just the
final pieces of these things but I mean
you picture the scale of what they did
this season and then the puzzle it's
like what like what hell crazy thing are
they gonna throw City next what weird
whispers zero our binary hexagon puzzle
combination of crazy smart people
puzzles is gonna hit us next time like
we get to one of these it's like you can
only imagine what they're gonna do to us
next but it is kind of pretty amazing
what we went through this past couple
weeks absolutely
life lifelong friendships gained
watching the whole community come
together and do this this is my favorite
thing about destiny is watching the
community just go crazy with each other
the people that I've met through this
that I'm in contact with obviously
because I was also engaged in the other
teams visits the number is astronomical
I can't even work my disk or tin box
right now like it's broken and that's a
good thing that's all this is the type
of thing and and you know it
people may look at this whole puzzle
thing and be like well I wasn't directly
involved with you know the core team so
I didn't really gain anything out of
this but you did because being part of
this core team helped me make
friendships yes but there are so many
places in the Destiny community where
this same thing is going on and and
there's there's people that run zero
hour every week there's people that run
whisper every week mm there's their
Sherpas that you can have teacher raids
in fact it's there's so many discourse
as well okay all this being pulled
together into we may be individual small
little groups in the destiny to
community but when we come together were
some of the smartest the strongest the
funniest and the most caring individuals
that I've ever come in contact with in
the community well sit there's no game
like destiny no it's not even because
I'm being biased I'm old I've been
around
there's no game like this I've never
played a game this long had this type of
an attachment to it and like you said
births those kinds of relationships it's
it's it's a different level and you even
see it with the charities our Saint Jude
it's just it's it's it's amazing and
like I said I'd love to see what journey
continues America it is really truly a
special game that we learn
well just to respect your time as well I
don't want to keep you forever because I
feel like we can talk about this thing
until we yeah we will so we don't want
you to get back into that state so we do
want to wrap it up but for anybody out
there whether it be audio or video where
you guys watch this one
ether for you let them know where they
can find you what you like doing and
just you know gamertags whatever you
want to share that is up to you man if
you stream if you're on Twitter if you
put at YouTube throw it all out there so
all the awesome people can find you and
send you a little more love than they
already have
absolutely um well first of all I just
want to say if you were involved in this
I go to ghost of Osiris calm and and put
your name in because we want to fill
that webpage with Guardians um so where
you can find me so I'm a third or a th
er lor and you can find me on instagram
you can find me you I'm most active on
Twitter I stream on Twitch I do have a
youtube that's under R infinity mom and
and my links are all attached together
so you go to one of those locations
you'll find me everywhere else you can
find my tik-tok like like my name is the
same across everything so just choose
your preferred method of whether
watching or listening or engaging type
in my name I'm there and I would love to
get to know you in this tremendous and
again as a e th e RL o r e so make sure
you get the spelling right follow
Granderson in the community it has been
an absolute pleasure having Zack or if
you are still out there listening and
having you on today will definitely haul
you know definitely thank you very much
ob katie-cat thank you for being in chat
today I know you're part of this group
as well so thank you for being in there
the rest of you guys in chat have been
awesome I got out sandy vagabond au
Prescott dramatic all you guys in chat
now Hugh are you guys are awesome I
can't list everybody malaria just seeing
what I see on screen right now Matic
coming in late of course wake up earlier
buddy of course but seriously for being
in shape being here today with us
like this was this was amazing to get a
piece of like just the inside
perspective whatever team you were in to
be truly Lake in the middle of the chaos
is a cool and respective to see cuz
understanding things of like Google
saying like hey stop deep like where you
think you're deep like to hear those
little bits is awesome so yeah play
those little nuggets were great one
quick thing I definitely want to salute
and we can't forget I want to shout out
Joshua reading aka ancient of frost
because technically he's the one that
helped put this whole thing together you
know he's the one that reached out to
both eat the core and eat the Lord
inside core I get that so similarly so
you know reach out to both you know both
of you and um you know find out all the
amazing work that you guys did and you
know he's our again our lords of gaming
net editor tremendous got huge destiny
fan always writes the best desk the
article for our site so salut ancient of
frost the only reason why you couldn't
be here because his wife's having a baby
he was gonna be here and he's still
listening I know he's listening too late
yeah we appreciate you he even had
specific questions we all right we got
you we share this this whole thing like
like those days just muddled together
into this absolute chaos and I'm
personally still trying to squirt
through it so being as these questions
help me kind of like put words around
the entire so I appreciate you guys of
course for talking to me and about this
whole thing because it's really exciting
to talk about and I really enjoy this
experience and I want to share it with
as many people as I can so thank you for
letting me get that out there yeah
absolutely
we'll do a wrapped up real quick and
then we will wrap this thing up so
kognito a quick wrap up for you and then
I will send us off into the world of our
Fridays yeah well first we shout the e
you know I'm Sam but put my I got my
little by little logo I got my Twitter
handle at the violet I'm getting all
fancy out here bad so yeah you can file
via Twitter at low incognito you already
know and
sunday is the Lord's Day a little
podcast will we talk about gaming
console pc will have a different guest
we have our michael Mercy's gonna talk
some retro some classic video game
systems back in the day and then talk
about the latest things that's going on
with the PlayStation 5 the Xbox series X
PC and all that good stuff so come check
us out that will be on the iron Lord
podcast YouTube channel 1:00 p.m.
Eastern on Sunday and of course please
check out Lords of gaming dotnet like I
mentioned Josh redditor reading our
editor-in-chief he's on there tons of
our gaming articles check that out and
last but not least every Friday 9:00
a.m. Eastern the best damn destiny
podcast yeah I don't know about which
I'm gonna learn y'all gonna learn the
last word with my guy Eve artists you
know we kill it every day we just try to
do stuff positive stuff for the
community and we appreciate the support
we see you guys retweeting and liking
the content so you know we love it it
feels good and we're gonna continue to
do this thing because we still love this
damn game that's all I got yeah we're
crazy so from the podcast that started
during curse of Osiris and people like
yelled crazy yeah we started it and the
lowest of the low yeah but yeah now
honestly just thank you to everybody in
chat today thank you to the entire
community for doing everything that you
did whether you were making the program
submitting images or just watching in
like you know supporting GLAAD inch you
guys broke glad you brought sweat circle
like so many people in just like thee
sub trains and the support and the love
that was given through this community
whether it was just like bits types
follows all those things that you guys
did in the community you broke some of
those streamers
I think sleep broke glad I saw you guys
like made light sweat cycle go like just
kind of get up out of his chair and just
like lose it from some of the love that
you guys gave and that's why again when
you guys say like the way this community
is unique unlike any other continues to
show itself there is no other community
that gets together but does what it does
that does guardian Connor and raises
four million dollars for st. Jude's like
the everything that happens is amazing
this is just another testament to during
all of this insanity going on you had
some like there were phases to it maybe
you weren't a streamer but like
everybody coming together was amazing so
thank you guys I'm simple I'm a mantis
everywhere twitch Twitter YouTube all
the good things so find me on any of
those and we're gonna try this with
three people it's always interesting as
the title of the podcast is the last
word this is how we wrap it up so I'll
can I give the little outro and then I'm
gonna say and it has been and who tries
to say the last word at the same time
don't wait on me I will try and match
you cool we go further we get you guys
go first cuz I gotta match you cuz the
delay is so and I can always edit it
later which I'm better at now so editing
always makes it easy so well thank you
guys very much it has been episode 88
for all of you guys in chat listening
out there in the world thank you guys
very much it has been January 24th
episode 88 and for all you guys out
there it has been all right
so I'm gonna send you guys over to Drew
ski he's out there playing some PvP
right now he's an awesome guy I met him
at Guardian John as well definitely one
I would not want to face in PvP because
I would get whooped but outside of that
I'm gonna send you guys to raid him so
do that right now give him some love
over on that side and as for the last
word today we're out of here so go enjoy
the raid I'll see you guys soon
and we are off